keeping ginette et docteur bach etc
comme chaque jeudi l'équipe de la
semaine prochaine réunis pour une séance
de travail
mon mari lui mb une bonne vie si à la
semaine prochaine est aujourd'hui un
succès à la première émission ce n'était
pas si évident on avait une piscine on
avait ainsi qu'est ce je voulais des
bruits d'eau je la mette plein avait
plein les arrêts aux patrons de
radio-canada
c'était pourri heureusement c'est ainsi
car la semaine prochaine est devenue
l'émission nationale d'ici radio-canada
première la plus écoutée au pire
c'est ce qui fait la valeur de cette
émission là c'est que les gens sentent
le pied c'est qu'on est seul face à
saintes 1 je suis que montréal est la
capitale mondiale de semaine après
semaine
l'équipe passe en revue les événements
marquants il nous fait rire avec des
personnages c'est le viol alors oui ce
qui existe est pauvre et certaines de
leurs imitations de personnalités
connues sont devenus des chouchous du
public en disant à la semaine prochaine
ses 271 émission près de 900000 texte et
50 mille coupures au montage
ce soir au théâtre saint-denis pour
l'enregistrement de cette émission
dixième anniversaire
ce sera assurément la fête on a écrit
des choses spéciales on s'en vient
vraiment du plaisir à nos fans et on a
un banc aujourd'hui on est tout excité
de ça s'il n'en tient qu'à l'équipe
laventure pourrait se poursuivre encore
longtemps
pour le plus grand plaisir des fans
[Musique]
si mélanie boissonneault radio canada
montréal